we sometimes not too sure how we get
into good friendships it seems to happen
rather mysteriously we talk of somewhat
randomly clicking with people trying to
plan for this sounds like cheating but
there is something at the heart of many
friendships that seems important to
identify and in a way to get good at
vulnerability it's too easy to assume
that what makes us likable or our
strengths our accomplishments the things
were proud of certainly this impresses
but it isn't what draws others to us we
get close to someone the more they and
we find ourselves able gracefully to
depart from the official story of what
human beings are like and can start to
show the awkward truths which underlie
the cheerful facade these are the truths
with which we've been lonely for too
long
how unlike normal sexuality our sex
lives actually are how full of envy our
careers are proving how unsatisfactory
our family can be how worried we are all
the time revealing any of these things
places us in great danger
others could laugh social media would
have a field day that's the point we can
only get close by revealing things which
would in the wall hairs be capable of
inflicting appalling humiliation on us
friendship is the dividend of gratitude
that flows from an acknowledgment that
once offered something very valuable to
someone not a fancy present but
something even more precious the key to
one's self esteem ducati it's deeply
poignant that we should expend so much
effort on trying to look strong before
the world when all the while it's really
only ever the revelation of the somewhat
embarrassing sad melancholy and anxious
bits of us that are what makes us
endearing to others and can transform
strangers into friends
you
you